Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 卧槽这个他妈的
Shure: Damn, this is freaking awesome.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 跨肩膀肩膀跨
Shure: Cross the shoulder, shoulder cross.
Shure: 这几个关节好像
Shure: These joints seem...
Lucia: 预备
Lucia: Ready.
Shure: 还扎马步
Shure: Still in horse stance.
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Shure: 张元英转圈是吧
Shure: Is Zhang Yuanying spinning around?
Shure: 不行这真不会啊
Shure: No way, I really can't do this.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha: 难度不对吧
Tasha: Isn't the difficulty level off?
Shure: 这是0.5倍速是吗
Shure: Is this 0.5x speed?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Shure: one two three four
Shure: One two three four
Shure: one two three four 1234
Shure: One two three four 1234
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Lucia: 哎好快这一边
Lucia: Oh, this side is really fast.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah ah
Shure: 哎不行了不行了
Shure: Oh no, I can't do it anymore.
Katrina: 先把前两部分
Katrina: Let's do the first two parts first.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh
Nicous: 今天到此为止哈哈哈
Nicous: That's it for today, hahaha
Jake:再来一次再来一次
Jake: Let's do it again, one more time.
Katrina: 把前两部分回顾一下
Katrina: Let's review the first two parts.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Nicous: 我们放前两个吧
Nicous: Let's play the first two parts.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Shure: 脑容量要炸了
Shure: My brain is about to explode.
Katrina: 手机呢调往前调一下
Katrina: Where's the phone? Rewind it a bit.
Jake:放哪了
Jake: Where did you put it?
Katrina: 你是要录我们刚刚跟音乐的吗
Katrina: Are you recording us with the music we just played?
Katrina: 还是从头
Katrina: Or from the beginning?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Jake:就是你们来跳一次比较完整的就行
Jake: Just do a complete run-through once, that's fine.
Shure: 那我们给大家展示一下这个第一部分
Shure: Then let's show everyone the first part.
Shure: 我们跳的最好的这一部分吧
Shure: The part we are best at.
Jake:全景相机
Jake: Panoramic camera
Jake:就是相当于这边处一人看你们
Jake: It's like having someone here watching you.
Shure: OK准备好了吗
Shure: OK, are you ready?
其他人：现在已经忘记了
Shure: 234567822
Shure: 三四五六七八三二三四五六七八四
Shure: 345678 32345678 4
Jake:二三四好
Jake: 234 good
Shure: 二三起 1234张12中2
Shure: 23 go 1234 Zhang 12 middle 2
Shure: 二三二三四把来二三滑
Shure: 23234 come on 23 slide
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Jake:牛啊你这个
Shure: 伸二比心张
Shure: Stretch, two, heart shape, open.
Shure: 二三走一二
Shure: Two, three, go, one, two.
Shure: 二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 一二三四五六七八
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 踏步二一二三四
Shure: March, two, one, two, three, four.
Shure: 一二三四跑
Shure: One, two, three, four, run.
Shure: 跳二三四
Shure: Jump, two, three, four.
Shure: 张二收二三四划二三四
Shure: Open, two, close, two, three, four, draw, two, three, four.
Shure: 摸手二三四顶二三四
Shure: Touch hand, two, three, four, lift, two, three, four.
Shure: 二三四一二三停
Shure: Two, three, four, one, two, three, stop.
Shure: 简单
Shure: Simple.
Katrina: 第二部分要不要再过一遍
Katrina: Should we go over the second part again?
Shure: 来第二部分
Shure: Let's do the second part.
Shure: 再跟他过一遍
Shure: Go over it again with him.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Katrina: 哇你就这么自信的吗
Katrina: Wow, are you that confident?
Jake:这是OK
Jake: This is okay.
Lucia: 这三部分加起来
Lucia: These three parts combined...
Lucia: 好像没有到完整的时长
Lucia: ...don't seem to be the full duration.
Lucia: 那就从头单曲循环
Lucia: Then let's loop it from the beginning.
Shure: 一二三四二二三四一二甩
Shure: One, two, three, four, two, two, three, four, one, two, flick.
Shure: 二张二开二一二三四
Shure: Two, open, two, spread, two, one, two, three, four.
Lucia: 等一下太快了
Lucia: Wait, too fast.
Shure: 41234223412
Shure: Four, one, two, three, four, two, two, three, four, one, two.
Shure: 对go一二三四五六七八
Shure: 二二三四五六七八
Shure: Two, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Shure: 转胯三四五六拍拍
Shure: Twist hips, three, four, five, six, clap, clap.
Shure: 一二三四五六七停
Shure: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, stop.
Lucia: 我觉得第二趴还是练一下吧
Lucia: I think we should still practice the second part.
Shure: sorry sorry
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 因为手和脚上动作要合一下
Lucia: Because we need to sync the hand and foot movements.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:好好下一个环节
Jake: Okay, onto the next segment.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Katrina: 好下一个环节
Katrina: Okay, next segment.
Jake:你的花
Katrina: 哦哦哦你说行行
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, you mean okay, okay.
其他人：跳舞结束了是吧
Jake:行吧
其他人：跳舞已经录了一个多小时了
Jake:好好好行
Shure: 呀呀呀呀呀呀呀
Shure: Ya ya ya ya ya ya ya.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake:都录着了
Jake: It's all recorded.
Jake:啊哈哈好
Jake: Ahaha, okay.
Katrina: 行吧去选花吧
Katrina: Alright, let's go pick flowers.
Shure: 他的出镜率不比他来的出镜率低是吧
Shure: His screen time isn't less than his arrival time, right?
Jake:对我们第第7位选手
Jake: Right, our 7th contestant.
Katrina: 几点钟了
Katrina: What time is it?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哦 4点了
Katrina: Oh, it's 4 o'clock.
Katrina: 是不是也得准备菜啥的啊
Katrina: Shouldn't we also prepare the dishes and stuff?
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, we should.
Katrina: 那就选一下花
Katrina: Then let's pick some flowers.
Jake:对拧个花就是我们的活动
Jake: Yes, picking flowers is part of our activity.
Jake:我们可以再给你跟跟剧组讲解一下我们的
Jake: We can also explain to you and the crew about our...
Jake:一些
Jake: some...
其他人：插花呗就是做个干花
Jake:也不是就是可能是7天
Jake: it's not really... maybe it's 7 days.
Jake:呃看着一一束花就长开
Jake: Uh, you see, a bouquet of flowers blooms over time.
Jake:走吧下去吧
Jake: Let's go downstairs.
其他人：延时摄影
Jake:延时摄影
其他人：对啊就是就是
Jake:昂
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:得一直处于摄像头上
Jake: He should always be on camera.
Jake:那不行没有的话
Jake: It won't work if he isn't.
Lucia: 但是理论上说
Lucia: But theoretically,
Lucia: 最后跳怎样其实不是特别重要
Lucia: the final jump doesn't really matter.
Lucia: 对吧我们只要有这个数据
Lucia: Right? As long as we have the data.
Katrina: 写一下名字簿
Katrina: Write down the names.
Katrina: 然后贴挑一束花
Katrina: Then pick a bouquet.
Katrina: 然后每天要给他拍照
Katrina: And take pictures every day.
Katrina: 对因为有了花苞
Katrina: Yes, because there are buds.
Katrina: 这就是他会慢慢盛开
Katrina: They will slowly bloom.
Katrina: 写名字写名字贴
Katrina: Write the name, write the name and stick it.
Shure: 写名字
Shure: Write the name.
Jake:写名字写呗
Jake: Write the name, go ahead.
Katrina: 那这我挑了
Katrina: Alright, I'll pick this one.
Shure: 谁让你挑的呵呵呵
Katrina: 偷偷挑的
Katrina: Picked it secretly.
Katrina: 挑是最好的
Katrina: Picking is the best.
Katrina: 今晚上还可以再练
Katrina: We can practice again tonight.
Jake:哎你你俩有
Jake: Hey, you two have...
Shure: 我要这个了
Shure: I'll take this one.
Jake:有你俩事
Jake: ...something to do.
Jake:你俩导个数据
其他人：ok
Jake:来
Katrina: 我的草莓种
Katrina: My strawberry seeds.
Jake:到位了啊兄弟们到位了
Jake: It's all set, guys, it's all set.
Tasha: 嗯哦
Tasha: Hmm, oh.
Tasha: 这有人了
Tasha: There's someone here.
Tasha: 名花有主了
Tasha: The flower is taken.
Tasha: 那就你吧
Tasha: Then it's you.
Jake:这个电源呢
Jake: Where's the power supply?
Jake:他的电源那儿去了
Jake: Where did his power supply go?
Katrina: 都都放了芍药的球球
Katrina: All the peony bulbs are placed.
其他人：少把椅子再搬把椅子
其他人：不是那种
其他人：这是
Jake:对
Katrina: 自己房间装饰
Katrina: Decorating my own room.
Lucia: 可以把它融入到我们的房间装饰里
Lucia: We can incorporate it into our room decor.
Katrina: 你也可以把它放在这客厅某一个位置
Katrina: You can also place it somewhere in the living room.
Tasha: 嗯这怎么断了一根
Tasha: Hmm, why is one broken?
Shure: Dyson i need a corporation
Shure: Dyson, I need a cooperation.
Jake:哪去了
Jake: Where did it go?
Shure: 这个放哪呢
Shure: Where should this go?
Shure: 我那面是阴面不宜养花
Shure: My side is shady, not good for growing flowers.
其他人：这是type c吗
Jake:不是是跟他一样
Jake: No, it should be like his.
Jake:跟跟左边的一样
Jake: Like the one on the left.
Lucia: 我觉得我房间要放阳台上
Lucia: I think I should put it on my balcony.
Lucia: 挺容易掉下来的
Lucia: It might fall off easily.
Lucia: 因为我那阳台它并不大
Lucia: Because my balcony isn't that big.
Choiszt: 就就就这个侧围
Choiszt: Just this side fence.
Jake:呃等下找不着了
Jake: Uh, wait a minute, can't find it.
Jake:挑完了吗大伙
Jake: Is everyone done knocking?
其他人：我我我记得我拿了
Shure: I, I, I remember I took it.
Jake:对啊我也觉得
Jake: Yeah, I think so too.
Jake:你拿下来了
Jake: Did you take it down?
Jake:那你放哪去
Jake: Where did you put it?
Jake:放哪去了
Jake:在冰箱里
Jake: In the fridge.
Choiszt: 这儿这个这个是不是
Choiszt: Is this the one?
Jake:昂确实牛逼
Jake: Yeah, that's really impressive.
Jake:幸亏他妈的来个可乐
Alice:让我给他修剪一下
Alice: Let me trim it a bit.
Lucia: 有一点点背光
Lucia: There's a bit of backlight.
Jake:挑好了吗
Jake: Is it adjusted?
Katrina: 挑好了
Katrina: It's done.
Alice:这个是可以剪花的
Alice: This one can be trimmed for flowers.
Jake:给我留的哪个呀
Jake: Which one is saved for me?
Tasha: 那要不拿昨天那个剪
Tasha: How about using yesterday's one?
Katrina: 是不是最里面那个这个这
Katrina: Is it the innermost one, this one?
Alice:昨天那个在哪
Alice: Where's yesterday's one?
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Jake:这什么花呀
Jake: What flower is this?
Katrina: 这是芍药
Katrina: This is a peony.
Katrina: 这应该也是芍药
Katrina: This should also be a peony.
Katrina: 这是康乃馨
Katrina: This is a carnation.
Katrina: 然后这是百合
Katrina: And this is a lily.
Alice:哎剪子在哪里
Alice: Hey, where are the scissors?
Katrina: 就买了这几种
Katrina: I only bought these types.
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: Here they are.
Alice:剪花的那个
Alice: The flower cutting scissors.
Shure: 我给自己的花起个名吧
Shure: I'll name my flower.
Katrina: sunshine好土
Katrina: Sunshine sounds so tacky.
Katrina: 你可以叫sunshine或者叫smile
Katrina: You can call it Sunshine or Smile.
Shure: smart可还行
Shure: Smart sounds okay.
Katrina: 微笑
Katrina: Smile.
Jake:嗯有电
Jake: Hmm, there's power.
Jake:这个不能乱关
Jake: This one shouldn't be turned off randomly.
Jake:所以关了硬盘就会好
Jake: So turning it off will fix the hard drive?
Jake:然后搞成这个样子
Jake: And then it ended up like this.
Jake:血汗工厂开店
Jake: Sweatshop opened. 社会问题
Nicous: 这个也要报
Nicous: We need to report this too.
Jake:你你们进去吧
Jake: You guys go in.
Jake:这这两个给你们
Jake: Here, these two are for you.
Katrina: 哇好像那是自习室啊
Katrina: Wow, that looks like a study room.
Jake:这
Jake: This...
Katrina: 就是那补习班
Katrina: It's just like a tutoring center.
Jake:哎呦让我出去
Jake: Oh, let me out.
Katrina: 然后现在推门进去减负
Katrina: And now we push the door open to reduce the burden.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, yes.
Jake:血汗工厂
Jake: Sweatshop.
Katrina: 不准办补习班
Katrina: No tutoring centers allowed.
Lucia: 不可翻译
Lucia: Untranslatable.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈太搞笑了
Katrina: Hahaha, that's hilarious.
Jake:不准办公
Jake: No office work allowed.
Lucia: 不准办公
Lucia: No office work allowed.
Jake:禁止办公
Jake: Office work is prohibited.
Jake:这边贴一个禁止办公
Jake: Let's stick a 'No Office Work' sign here.
Lucia: 这标这标语我喜欢
Lucia: I like this slogan.
Katrina: 拍拍坐像那种
Katrina: Take a photo sitting like that.
Shure: 你们你们仨是网吧
Shure: You three are like an internet cafe.
Shure: 3连坐是吗
Shure: Triple seats, right?
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的像
Katrina: Hahaha, it really looks like it.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这外面这桌子是不是有点有点歪
Lucia: Is this table outside a bit crooked?
Lucia: 这个板
Lucia: This board...
Lucia: 不是就是这板好像不太平
Lucia: No, this board seems uneven.
Jake:对对对是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes, it is.
Jake:他就是不够
Jake: It's just not enough.
Jake:哈哈哈很勉强
Jake: Hahaha, very makeshift.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Jake:不过也行这样就好
Jake: But it's fine, it's good like this.
Shure: 你们仨准备打点什么
Shure: What are you three planning to play?
Shure: 英雄联盟吗
Shure: League of Legends?
Jake:三个人能打什么呀
Jake: What can three people play?
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Can you hold this for me?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah?
Alice:斗地主
Alice: Landlord.
Lucia: 三个人
Lucia: Three people...
Jake:帮我拿一下
Jake: Can you hold this for me?
Shure: 三个人APEX
Shure: Three people for APEX
Lucia: 三个人可以
Lucia: Three people, sure
Lucia: 三个人可以联机玩刺客信条黑棋
Lucia: Three people can play Assassin's Creed: Black Flag together
Shure: 可以永结无间
Shure: We can form an unbreakable bond
Jake:好好好行了行了
Jake: Alright, alright, that's enough
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: Sounds good, sounds good
Jake:这样好
Jake: This is good
Shure: 这是干嘛的呀
Shure: What's this for?
Lucia: 做引体向上的哈哈哈
Lucia: For doing pull-ups, hahaha
Katrina: 做引体销售
Katrina: For pull-up sales
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 挂个杆然后做引体向上是吗
Shure: Hang a bar and do pull-ups, right?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Right, right, right
Jake:行行行挺好挺好
Jake: Alright, alright, sounds good, sounds good
Jake:挺好挺好挺好挺好
Jake: Sounds good, sounds good, sounds good, sounds good
Lucia: 我们乱说的
Lucia: We're just talking nonsense
Lucia: 小心一点
Lucia: Be careful
Shure: 主要我撑不起来
Shure: Mainly, I can't pull myself up
Shure: 需要给他修剪吗
Shure: Does it need trimming?
Katrina: 随便你你的话
Katrina: Up to you
Lucia: 你想修的话可以修呀
Lucia: If you want to trim it, go ahead
Jake:行也不用那么高
Jake: Alright, it doesn't need to be that high
Shure: 我不修因为我姓
Shure: I won't trim because my last name is...
Jake:就你就卡到这就行
Jake: Just stop here
Shure: 修了一下
Shure: Trimmed it a bit
Lucia: 哦哦
Lucia: Oh, oh
Alice:不缺修
Alice: No need to trim
Jake:高了我怕他摔
Jake: If it's too high, I'm afraid he'll fall
Jake:你看这个就是我的床的入口
Jake: Look, this is the entrance to my bed
Lucia: 为什么这几个球球到现在还没有开
Lucia: Why are these balls still not opened?
Jake:全自动全自动入口你说
Jake: Fully automatic, you said
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 你能过来吗
Shure: Can you come over here?
Jake:哈哈哈能啊这个一跳我就上上床
Jake: Hahaha, sure, I just need to jump to get on the bed
Shure: 这么大地
Shure: It's this big
Jake:对上床入口
Jake: Yes, bed entrance
Shure: 我靠哎呦喂sorry
Shure: Oh my, oops, sorry
Lucia: sorry一跳就上涨了可爱笑
Lucia: Sorry, one jump and it goes up, so cute
Jake:对哈哈对对对入口
Jake: Yes haha, yes yes, the entrance.
Katrina: 嗯理想中的房间
Katrina: Hmm, the ideal room.
Katrina: 哈哈哈学习完倒头就睡
Katrina: Haha, finish studying and fall asleep immediately.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Jake:饶了我吧哈哈哈
Jake: Spare me, haha.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Lucia: 这个确实是软件工程理想中的房间了
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 对写完代码直接倒头就睡
Katrina: Yeah, finish coding and fall asleep right away.
Jake:哎盘呢
Jake: Hey, where's the plate?
Lucia: 啊哪哪个
Lucia: Ah, which one?
Jake:哦哦哦对对对刚刚对刚刚
Jake: Oh oh oh, yes, the one just now.
Lucia: 刚拿过来的这个吗
Lucia: The one we just brought over?
Katrina: 哎二楼这投影仪也可以
Katrina: Hey, this projector on the second floor is nice too.
Katrina: 那款放点music可以吗
Katrina: Can we play some music on it?
Jake:对一楼也是
Shure: ；来点music
Katrina: yes反正戴了眼镜了
Katrina: Yes, since we are wearing glasses anyway.
Jake:来点music
Jake: Play some music.
Katrina: 已经录下来
Katrina: It's already recorded.
Jake:你们你们要现在是要干啥呀按照
Jake: What do you all want to do now?
Katrina: 我们可以讨论一下
Katrina: We can discuss...
Katrina: 我们的那个房间装饰
Katrina: ...our room decorations.
Katrina: 你不说要录录录下来吗
Katrina: Didn't you say to record everything?
Jake:对对然后这个他们应该
Jake: Yes, yes, and they should...
Jake:他说是4五点会有人过来收拾
Jake: He said someone would come to clean around 4 or 5.
Jake:对然后那会收拾
Jake: Yes, and then when they clean...
Jake:收拾完我们就扫房间
Jake: After they clean, we'll scan the room.
Jake:就是扫3D扫
Jake: We'll do a 3D scan.
Jake:嗯对我靠
Jake: Yeah, oh my.
Jake:4399 呵呵呵
Jake: 4399, haha.
Katrina: 那几点准备食材呢
Katrina: When are we preparing the ingredients?
Shure: 死神vs火影
Shure: Death Note vs. Naruto.
Shure: 这不得来一把
Shure: We gotta play a round.
Jake:呃对那要不现在就开始准备食材吧
Jake: Uh, how about we start preparing the ingredients now?
Jake:然后
Jake: And then...
Jake:对现在开始准备食材
Jake: Yes, let's start preparing the ingredients now.
Jake:就现在就看一看
Jake: Just take a look now.
Jake:准备准备
Jake: Get ready.
Katrina: 现在也可以看那个房间装饰购买
Katrina: Now we can also look at buying room decorations.
Jake:也可以
Jake: Yes, we can.
Katrina: 然后5点他来收拾然后扫房间
Katrina: Then at 5, he will come to tidy up and clean the room.
Katrina: 我们只需要稍微
Katrina: We just need to...
Tasha: 把我的也修一下吧
Tasha: Fix mine too, please.
Katrina: 收拾一下我们就下来忙这个呗
Katrina: Tidy up a bit and then we'll get busy with this.
Katrina: 对扫房间
Katrina: Yes, clean the room.
Katrina: 扫房间是你们三个弄是吧
Katrina: You three will handle cleaning the room, right?
Jake:呃这打扫房间是不是
Jake: Uh, cleaning the room, right?
Jake:嗯不用不用
Jake: Hmm, no, no.
Jake:我们都不用弄
Jake: We don't need to do it.
Katrina: OK那我们那个吧
Katrina: OK, then let's...
Tasha: 是那你先放也行
Tasha: You can put it there first.
Katrina: 我看我要买什么
Katrina: I'll see what I want to buy.
Jake:OK来关掉4399
Jake: OK, turn off 4399.
Katrina: 我想买那我想搞成那种森林主题
Katrina: I want to buy and make it a forest theme.
Jake:然后那个上上卡
Jake: And then top up the card.
Lucia: 我我没想好我要怎么样
Lucia: I haven’t decided what I want yet.
Katrina: 搞全绿色
Katrina: Make it all green.
Lucia: 我想我想借一个同学的作业抄一下
Lucia: I want to borrow a classmate’s homework to copy.
Katrina: 还有
Katrina: Also...
Katrina: 也可
Katrina: We can...
Alice:我本来想弄蓝的
Alice: I originally wanted blue.
Alice:后来发现蓝的太难买
Alice: But then I found blue was too hard to buy.
Alice:然后昨天晚上也挑了绿的
Alice: So last night, I chose green instead.
Jake:这什么意思啊
Jake: What does this mean?
Katrina: 以
Katrina: Uh...
其他人：这个11号啊
Jake:为什么是这个
Jake: Why this?
其他人：对啊为什么是这个
Tasha: 这衣服该放在哪里呢
Tasha: Where should I put these clothes?
Alice:我先找一堆绿的我喜欢
Alice: I’ll find a bunch of green ones I like first.
Katrina: 你房间有那个钩子吗
Katrina: Does your room have hooks?
Alice:青一点的绿
Alice: A lighter green.
Tasha: 好吧咖啡
Tasha: Okay, coffee.
Katrina: 就是我房间有两个钩子
Katrina: My room has two hooks.
Katrina: 我感觉可以买那种挂画海报呢
Katrina: I think we can buy those hanging posters.
Katrina: 因为他不给贴
Katrina: Because we can't stick them up.
Shure: 这样吧我们建一个歌单
Shure: Let's create a playlist.
Shure: 然后大家一人报一个歌名好吧
Shure: Then everyone suggests a song, okay?
Tasha: 嗯好像也没有很乱
Tasha: Hmm, it doesn't seem that messy.
Tasha: 这两个是退的
Tasha: These two are for returns.
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Exactly, exactly.
Katrina: 大家可以想听什么自己输进去
Katrina: Everyone can input whatever they want to hear.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 然后我们搞随机播放
Katrina: Then we can do a random shuffle.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 哇有点像那个随机舞蹈了哈哈
Katrina: Wow, it's kinda like a random dance, haha.
Shure: 来大家先一人说一个歌名
Shure: Alright, everyone name a song first.
Shure: 我先都不放
Shure: I won't play any yet.
Shure: 然后都加到歌单里
Shure: Then we'll add them all to the playlist.
Shure: 然后这个歌单随便放可以吧
Shure: And then we can shuffle play the playlist, sound good?
Katrina: 上想听的歌
Katrina: Add the songs you want to hear.
Lucia: 我打开我的apple music
Lucia: I'll open my Apple Music.
Katrina: 好有意思啊
Katrina: This is so interesting.
Lucia: 然后突然发现
Lucia: And then I suddenly realized...
Lucia: 我的我的APP账号没登在里面
Lucia: I haven't logged into my APP account.
Jake:我操没关系没关系没关系没关系
Jake: Damn, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 所以找不到自己签的歌单了
Lucia: So I can't find my signed playlists.
Lucia: 我得重新登录一下
Lucia: I need to log in again.
Jake:我我我觉
Jake: I, I think...
Jake:11号
Jake: Number 11.
Shure: 爱很简单真的吗
Shure: "Love is Simple," really?
Jake:看一看你看一看
Jake: Look, look.
Jake:看看这里面是什么东西
Jake: Let's see what's in here.
Katrina: 哇这首歌每次都是演唱会的压轴
Katrina: Wow, this song is always the finale at concerts.
Tasha: 这是用来干什么的
Tasha: What's this for?
Jake:他难道会这有人换吗
Jake: Is someone supposed to change this?
Jake:11号没人换是吧
Jake:换换下来就是这个
Jake: Change it, and it's this one.
Jake:看看有没有
Jake: Let's see if there is...
Jake:东西万一要是原来送一个256
Jake: Something, just in case it sends a 256.
其他人：我看一眼
Jake:等一下等一下我试试
其他人：我觉得是这个
Jake:哎可以
Jake: Hey, it's okay.
其他人：这电脑有吗
Jake:一样
Jake: Same.
Jake:右边没有吗
Jake: Not on the right?
Jake:不是不是他
Jake: No, no, he...
Jake:你左边没有吗
Jake: Don't you have it on your left?
Jake:我靠你他妈同款电脑我都学不会
Jake: Damn, I can't learn anything even with the same computer.
Jake:哈哈哈你搞笑了
Jake: Hahaha, you're hilarious.
Jake:我靠哈哈哈哈哈耶
Jake: Damn, hahaha, yeah!
Jake:我毫无encounter呢
Jake: I have no encounter.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Jake:毫无encounter
Jake: No encounter at all.
其他人：这弹的时候它这个
Jake:对
Jake:怎么说
其他人：就是i现在换的再重新重新校准
Jake:那个应该是被我清掉了
Jake: That one should have been cleared by me.
Jake:卡不一样也也行吧
Jake: Different cards are also fine, right?
Jake:但是很蠢
Jake: But it's really dumb.
Jake:就是这些不统一
Jake: These are just inconsistent.
Jake:14个 256的和一个128的
Jake: 14 of 256GB and one of 128GB.
其他人：你要今天晚上给他重新
Jake:对对对今晚加个班
Jake: Yeah yeah, let's work overtime tonight.
其他人：我也导怎么导
Jake:哎那个你你们你们排一下
Jake: Hey, you guys, line up.
Jake:等等一下等一下
Jake: Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Lucia: 有人要点歌吗
Lucia: Anyone wants to request a song?
Lucia: 3位要点歌吗
Lucia: Do any of the three of you want to request a song?
Jake:那不是修硕的事情吗点歌
Lucia: 点歌
Lucia: Pick a song.
Lucia: 不是要放是要放
Lucia: Are we playing it or not?
Tasha: 就这样吧
Tasha: Let's just do it like this.
Lucia: 要不要不让修硕谈
Lucia: Should we let Shure talk or not?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:等一下等一下等一下
Jake: Wait, wait, wait.
Jake:哎听我指挥
Jake: Hey, listen to me.
Jake:大家听我指挥
Jake: Everyone listen to me.
Jake:呃首先这个东西它在它是
Jake: Uh, first of all, this thing, it's...
Jake:哎为什么在我手上
Jake: Hey, why is it in my hand?
Jake:为什么在我手上
Jake: Why is it in my hand?
其他人：这个刚刚给你的11号
Jake:11号是吧
Jake: Is it number 11?
Jake:是11一号吗
其他人：对11号
Jake:别弄乱了弄乱傻逼了
Jake: Don't mess it up, you'll screw it up.
Jake:这个这个给我
Jake: This, this, give it to me.
其他人：这换吗
Jake:换
其他人：7
Jake:行
Jake:好这样这个这个是1111是空的
Jake: Alright, so, this one, this one is empty.
Jake:不管他然后你你这边手上是什么
Jake: Never mind that, and you, what do you have in your hand?
Jake:还没有一张还没有
Jake: We don't have it yet, we don't.
Jake:行这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's do it like this.
Jake:就是你这二楼的
Jake: So, you handle the second floor.
Jake:呃谢斌竹搞一楼的好吧
Jake: Uh, the video host will handle the first floor, okay?
其他人：他这个是视频音频我得
Jake:你你不用
Jake: You, you don't need to.
Jake:就是首先你下一个下一个
Jake: So, first, the next one, the next one.
Jake:VLC VLC VLC VLC啊
Jake: VLC, VLC, VLC, VLC.
Katrina: 他点了蝴蝶
Katrina: She picked "Butterfly."
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 你还你还你
Lucia: You still... you still...
Lucia: 还没点应该
Lucia: haven't chosen, right?
Shure: 还有谁没点
Shure: Who else hasn't chosen?
其他人：来一首陈奕迅
Jake:这边要点陈奕迅
Jake: Let's pick an Eason Chan song here.
其他人：来一首陈奕迅
Lucia: 浮夸
Lucia: We can choose two songs, maybe "Exaggerated."
其他人：来一首周杰伦的
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 周杰伦没有
Lucia: 陈奕迅和周杰伦
Lucia: Eason Chan and Jay Chou.
Katrina: 我想听那个爱是一本书
Katrina: I want to listen to "Love is a Book."
Katrina: 就是陈奕迅的爱是一本书
Katrina: The Eason Chan song "Love is a Book."
其他人：这个是什么这就插了
其他人：对
Jake:哎你这怎么
Jake: Hey, what are you...
其他人：你没插呀
Jake:你插那了
Jake: Where did you plug that in?
Lucia: 我也来帮陈奕迅点一个
Lucia: I'll help pick another Eason Chan song.
Jake:哎呦哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh my, oh my, what the...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:卧槽你你是几天没睡觉的
Jake: Wow, how many days have you not slept?
其他人：卧槽你把我打乱了把我的思维打乱了
Jake:呃你你等啊
Jake: Uh, you wait...
Jake:你你拧一下
Jake: Turn it a bit.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:拧一下你拧一下
Jake: Turn it, turn it a bit.
Jake:好你你是谁
Jake: Okay, who are you?
其他人：啊
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
其他人：什么我在下那个MP4
Jake:OK你现在电脑里面
Jake: Okay, now in your computer...
Jake:你你现在电脑里面是什么7号
Jake: What flag do you have in your computer now?
其他人：我现在是7号
Jake:7号拔出来
Jake:先不要7号
其他人：对我这个给他
Jake:对
其他人：还是的就是这么一下
其他人：因为点到格式化了
Choiszt: 这个其实咱装可以
Choiszt: Actually, we can install this.
Jake:没问题没问题没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem, no problem.
Shure: 就先放你这个吧好吧
Shure: Let's start with yours, alright?
Jake:7号
Jake: Number 7
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Jake:对然后呃谢斌竹从1号开始
Jake:稍微容易一点对你你稍微难一点
Jake: For you, it's going to be a bit more difficult
Jake:哈哈哈你从你从9号开始
Jake: Hahaha, you'll start from the 9th floor
Jake:8号在一楼
Jake: 8th floor is on the first floor
Jake:呃9号
Jake: Uh, 9th floor
其他人：11号少一个
Jake:对十一号跳过去
Jake: Yes, skip the 11th floor
其他人：这新买的红色的卡是256G的
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake:然后你们要做的事情是把每一层
Jake: And then what you need to do is make sure each floor
Jake:就是按楼层
Jake: According to each floor
Jake:这个是一楼
Jake: This is the first floor
Jake:哎这是一楼
Jake: Hey, this is the first floor
Jake:这是二楼
Jake: This is the second floor
Jake:然后我标一下
Jake: Let me mark it
Jake:给我一个那个纸
Jake: Give me that paper
Jake:便签纸便签纸都行
Jake: Sticky notes, sticky notes will do
其他人：谁点的这么有水平
Jake:还能是谁哈哈
Jake: Who else could it be, haha
Jake:对啊陶喆
Katrina: 哎呀怎么把我网名念出来了
Katrina: Oh no, why did you say my screen name out loud?
Jake:呵为什么还在3月2号
Jake: Haha, why is it still March 2nd
Lucia: 太激动了不想改
Lucia: Too excited, don't want to change it
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah
Jake:等到明年3月2号是吧
Jake: Until next March 2nd, right?
Katrina: 等到什么时候再看下一场了再改
Katrina: Until whenever, we'll see the next one and then change it
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina: 对我看第一场
Katrina: Yeah, I'll see the first one
Katrina: 在武汉我抢到了前区票
Katrina: 3月2号 哦
Katrina: March 2nd, oh
Katrina: 那时候刚来学校一会
Katrina: Just started school then
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Katrina: 但是但是
Katrina: But, but
Katrina: 他现在嗓子已经回春很多了
Katrina: His voice has recovered a lot now
Katrina: 他把那心乱肺的高音给飙上去
Katrina: He can hit those high notes with emotion again
Jake:那就整整火锅呗
Jake: Then let's have hotpot
Jake:然后聊一聊你们
Jake: And chat a bit
Katrina: 我要买一下我的东西
Katrina: I need to buy my stuff
Jake:好让数据丰富起来
Jake: Okay, let's enrich the data.
Katrina: 今天可丰富了
Katrina: It's really rich today.
Katrina: 今天还那么多肢体动作
Katrina: There are so many body movements today.
Jake:确实对现在也要丰富起来
Jake: Indeed, it needs to be rich now too.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 到现在还没想好买啥
Lucia: I still haven't decided what to buy.
Katrina: 其实现在好多那种
Katrina: Actually, there are many of those...
Katrina: 就是那种很有意思的做的家居品牌
Katrina: ...those interesting home decor brands.
Lucia: 我选一个整屋定制哈哈哈
Lucia: I'll choose a whole house customization, hahaha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization.
Katrina: 好好看哈哈
Katrina: It looks so good, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization.
Katrina: 你让杨老板给你报销
Katrina: Ask Jake to reimburse you.
Jake:外包是吧
Jake: Outsourcing, right?
Lucia: 对对对哈哈
Lucia: Yes, yes, haha.
Jake:外包呵呵
Jake: Outsourcing, haha.
Katrina: 整屋定制
Katrina: Whole house customization.
Jake:500块钱 200外包
Jake: 500 yuan, 200 for outsourcing.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:全程外包
Jake: Full outsourcing.
其他人：这个也要付费
Jake:不是不是VLC啊
Jake: It's not VLC, huh.
其他人：我下的是VLC
Jake:你这哪个VLC
Jake: Which VLC is this?
Jake:你这不是VLC
Jake: This is not VLC.
Jake:你们这
Jake: You all...
其他人：这个OK
Katrina: 我还有一个小阳台
Katrina: I have a small balcony.
Katrina: 我阳台上可以放东西
Katrina: I can put things on my balcony.
Jake:对对对video nine
Jake: Yes, yes, video nine.
Jake:这个是你
Jake: This is you...
Jake:你下盗版了
Jake:哈哈哈学学
Jake: Hahaha, learn from it.
Jake:挺准的你
Jake: You got it right.
Jake:呃这样你你跟他一样
Jake: Uh, like this, you're the same as him.
Jake:但是你这个可能不太稳
Jake: But this may not be stable.
Jake:不知道怎么办
Jake: Not sure what to do.
Jake:你腰部也低一点
Jake: Lower your waist a bit.
Jake:然后这个高一点
Jake: Then raise this part a bit.
Jake:我想想怎么办
Jake: Let me think about what to do.
Jake:因为
Jake: Because
Jake:因为你这个硬盘也要放在这个地方
Jake: Because you need to place this hard drive here.
Jake:然后但是这个硬盘你你不能摔着
Jake: But you can't drop the hard drive, you know?
Jake:你懂吗所以你行行行
Jake: Do you understand? Okay, okay.
Jake:哈哈哈可以然后插上
Jake: Haha, alright, then plug it in.
Katrina: 他们在工作
Katrina: They are working.
Lucia: 要不然我搞个照片墙
Lucia: Why don't I make a photo wall?
Katrina: 然后这边在放歌
Katrina: And play music here.
Katrina: 这边在剪花
Katrina: And cut flowers here.
Shure: 我给你们加油打气
Shure: I'll cheer you on.
Shure: 我给你们跳yes okay
Shure: I'll dance for you, yes okay.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哎
Lucia: Hahaha, hey.
Choiszt: 对唔出
Choiszt: Right, can't do it.
Lucia: 我觉得他动作已经很得精髓了
Lucia: I think he's really got the essence of the moves.
Jake:要不把碗洗了哈哈哈
Jake: How about washing the dishes, hahaha.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
其他人：先生你好把上传里的数据存进去
Jake:卧槽哈哈哈你怎么弄的
Jake: Damn, hahaha, how did you do it?
Jake:呃OK
Jake: Uh, OK.
Jake:那那你直接这样嘛
Jake: Then just do it like this.
Jake:你你觉得怎么样
Jake: What do you think?
Jake:贴着贴哎
Jake: Stick it, stick it.
Jake:能能贴吗贴着吧
Jake: Can you stick it? Stick it.
其他人：这拿着也行
Choiszt: Holding it is fine.
Jake:拿着不行贴着吧贴着好
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh.
Jake:拿个工具
Jake: Get a tool.
Jake:先贴硬盘
Jake: First stick the hard drive.
Jake:啊也行
Jake: Ah, that works too.
Jake:哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh damn.
Jake:呵呵呵挺好
Jake: Haha, pretty good.
Jake:没事没事
Jake: No worries, no worries.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: It's not a big deal.
Jake:竖着贴
Jake:哦那你看怎么贴
Jake: Oh, then see how to stick it.
Jake:爱爱咋贴咋贴
Jake: However you want to stick it, just stick it.
Jake:你弄矮一点
Jake: Make it lower.
其他人：可以可以很稳很稳
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:那贴一个
Jake: Then stick one.
Jake:等一下贴硬盘上 L 2
Jake: Wait a minute, stick it on the hard drive.
Katrina: 天呐好多好看的都是要做手工
Katrina: Oh my gosh, so many pretty things require handcrafting.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Katrina: 啊直接到浮夸了
Katrina: Ah, this is just too extravagant.
Jake:行你就教外国人用淘宝也挺好
Jake: Well, you can teach foreigners how to use Taobao, that's good too.
Jake:让他们羡慕去
Jake: Make them jealous.
Lucia: 有哪个购物平台给咱给赞助吗
Lucia: Is there any shopping platform sponsoring us?
Lucia: 就多用用他们的
Lucia: We can use their services more.
Jake:这还有个帽子还戴着呢哈
Jake: There's even a hat here, wearing it, huh.
Lucia: 啊亚马逊是吗
Lucia: Ah, is it Amazon?
Lucia: 他们已经会用了不用教
Lucia: They already know how to use it, no need to teach.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Katrina: 我要买几个摆在我那
Katrina: I want to buy a few to display at my place.
Jake:这就直接导
Jake: Just import it directly.
Jake:自然前面的数据都不太好
Jake: Naturally, the previous data isn't very good.
Jake:呃这个
Jake: Uh, this
Jake:你们这个硬盘里面贴这上面
Jake: You paste this inside your hard drive.
其他人：这个干什么的
其他人：这给我重贴一个
其他人：这给是谁的2好是谁的
Jake:我的
Jake:2号是第二层
Jake: Number 2 is the second layer.
Jake:所以对对对
Jake: So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:专门专门做Pro的第二层
Jake: Specifically, the second layer for the Pro.
Jake:然后你按照每一个相机
Jake: Then you follow each camera.
Jake:呃然后每一天
Jake: Uh, then each day.
其他人：ok每一个相机每一天
其他人：这个有用吗
Choiszt: 咱指导视频
Choiszt: Our guide video.
Jake:对指导视频制号MB4
Jake: Yes, guide video number MB4.
Jake:别的都不用
Jake: Nothing else is needed.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Choiszt: 然后这个是ER
Choiszt: And this is ER.
Choiszt: 就是顺序顺序
Choiszt: It's in order, order.
Jake:对你看它有时间
Jake: Right, look at its time.
Jake:你看它时间
Jake: Look at its time.
Jake:它的时间是准的
Jake: Its time is accurate.
Jake:然后你按照时间
Jake: Then you follow the time.
Jake:你你你弄到文件夹里
Jake: You, you, you put it in the folder.
Choiszt: 那这个具体是几号相机不用管
Choiszt: So we don't need to worry about which camera it is exactly?
Jake:这个你看
Jake: Look at this.
Jake:这不这你这是几号相机
Jake: Isn't this your camera number?
Choiszt: 哦哦哦哈哈
Choiszt: Oh, oh, oh, haha.
Jake:他会切自己会切
Jake: It will cut by itself, it will cut by itself.
Jake:呃我来跟你命名
Jake: Uh, let me name it for you.
Jake:看好看好
Jake: Watch closely, watch closely.
Jake:然后这个先上
Jake: And then put this on first.
Jake:先上这个盘对吧
Jake: Put this plate on first, right?
Jake:这个这个盘
Jake: This, this plate.
Jake:好呃呃
Jake: Okay, um, um...
Jake:还没连上
Jake: It's not connected yet.
Jake:连上
Jake: Connect it.
Jake:这个
Jake: This one.
Jake:后边后边
Jake: The back, the back.
Jake:插上了这边
Jake: Plug it in here.
Jake:谢斌竹我原来帮他插上了
Jake:然后你现在没有
Jake: And now you don't have it.
Jake:他要格式化一下
Jake:贴的不太对是吧
Jake: It's not sticking right, is it?
Jake:要不换个地方贴
Jake: Maybe stick it somewhere else.
Jake:你往下贴贴
Jake: Stick it lower.
Jake:其实就好
Jake: That should be fine.
Jake:我擦哈哈哈还是有点事
Jake: Oh shoot, there's still a bit of an issue.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Choiszt: 其实还行
Choiszt: Actually, it's okay.
其他人：这个线不会被窝就这样
其他人：还是得再高一点
Jake:搜搜计算机
Jake:计算机什么东西
Jake: What's with the computer?
Jake:管理对
Jake: Management, right.
Jake:呃硬盘
Jake: Uh, hard drive.
Jake:磁盘管理
Jake: Disk management.
Jake:呃格式化它
Jake:出了吗好
Jake: Is it out? Good.
Jake:啊确定
Jake: Ah, confirm.
Jake:一路确定下去
Jake: Confirm all the way.
其他人：哎怎么
Jake:你这没有
Jake: You don't have this.
Jake:那那再开一次
Jake:把这个关了
Jake: Turn this off.
Jake:重来一次
Jake:对好
Jake: Yes, good.
Jake:对GBT
Jake: Yes, GBT.
Jake:然后格式化
Jake:你你别格错了
Jake:好行
Jake: Alright, fine.
Jake:格格哈哈哈
Jake:格错了就他妈凉了
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Choiszt: 然后是
Choiszt: Then
Jake:格3个t的啊
Jake:新建新建
Jake: Create new, create new
Jake:新建简单卷
Jake:呃不用调
Jake:都不用调
Jake:对呃也不用调
Jake:全都不用调
Jake:还新加坡不用调
其他人：新加卷
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:好几天好几天
Jake: Several days, several days
Jake:好结束了
Jake: Alright, it’s done
Jake:然后放对
Jake: Then put it right
Jake:一般放个瓶
Jake: Usually, put a bottle
Jake:左边左边右边
Jake: Left, left, right
其他人：ok
Lucia: 啊你的这个也还没开
Lucia: Oh, yours hasn't bloomed yet either.
Alice:嗯还没有呢
Alice: Yeah, not yet.
Lucia: 我那个也是
Lucia: Mine's the same.
Lucia: 都还没开
Lucia: None of them have bloomed yet.
Alice:欣赏一下
Alice: Let's just enjoy it.
Jake:好看
Jake: Looks good.
Jake:是修剪了一遍
Jake: It's been pruned.
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
Jake:修剪了狠狠的修剪了一遍
Jake: Pruned really thoroughly.
Alice:也没有还很一般般
Alice: Not really, it's just okay.
Jake:确实好看了很多
Jake: It does look much better.
Lucia: 我好奇一下大家都写的什么符号
Lucia: I'm curious, what symbols did everyone draw?
Alice:我给他画的翅膀
Alice: I drew wings for it.
Lucia: 小翅膀
Lucia: Little wings.
Jake:翅膀但是画的有点丑
Jake: Wings, but they look kinda ugly.
Alice:但是画的有点丑
Alice: Yeah, they look kinda ugly.
Jake:还没写写一下
Jake: Haven't written it yet, write it down.
Alice:我是个星
Alice: I'm a star.
Lucia: 我是个小太阳
Lucia: I'm a little sun.
Lucia: 啊雨轩是直接写的名字
Lucia: Ah, Yuxuan wrote their name directly.
Katrina: 哦香薰
Katrina: Oh, essential oil.
Katrina: 我想买个小香薰
Katrina: I want to buy a small essential oil diffuser.
Lucia: 买一串星星灯
Lucia: Buy a string of star lights.
Lucia: 直接给房间上挂一圈就完事了
Lucia: Just hang them around the room, and you're done.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:这是我的
Jake: This is mine.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 他是什么花
Lucia: What kind of flower is it?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：我这里面这些东西怎么办
Jake:啊别的都不用
Jake: Ah, nothing else is needed.
Jake:就是只要MP4 其他的都不用
Jake:不用啊哎
Jake: No need, hey.
Jake:人呢他会吗
Jake: Will he do it?
Jake:尼玛哈哈哈你咋跑了
Jake: Damn it, hahaha, why did you run away?
Jake:回来了我擦
Jake: You're back, damn.
Jake:哈哈哈你结束
Jake: Hahaha, you're done.
其他人：我这已经结束了
Jake:尼玛不让你
Jake: Damn, not letting you.
Jake:哈哈哈 15十五号
Jake: Hahaha, 15th, the fifteenth.
Jake:十六号秒
Jake: Sixteenth second.
Jake:你这是不是
Jake: Is this it?
Jake:哎其实没毛病
Jake: Hey, actually no problem.
Jake:哈哈哈多少慢了点
Jake: Hahaha, just a bit slow.
Jake:只是慢了
Jake: Just a bit slow.
其他人：它这个最多插一个SD卡
Jake:嗯
其他人：有没有什么其他的
Jake:有读卡器可以买读卡器
Jake: If you have a card reader, you can buy a card reader.
其他人：就读卡器对对对
其他人：需要买吗
Jake:就一个硬盘啊
Jake: Just one hard drive.
其他人：不是你可以搞一个其他的
Jake:但是你速度我不知道
Jake: But your speed, I don't know.
Jake:你两个一起倒速度会有变化吗
Jake: Will the speed change if you copy two together?
Jake:呃应该就是很讲究的命名方式
Jake: Uh, it should be a very meticulous naming method.
Jake:是你呃你现在怎么命名呢
Jake: How do you name it now?
Jake:你现在就直接拖进去是吧
Jake: You just drag it in directly, right?
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn.
Jake:你他妈太粗暴了
Jake: You're too rough.
Jake:对对对太太太粗暴了
Jake: Yes, yes, too, too, too rough.
Jake:来来来这个法2好吧
Jake: Come on, come on, this method 2 is good, right?
Jake:呃那个你是几号相机
Jake: Uh, which camera number are you?
其他人：1号
Jake:那你写个一一新建文件加一
Jake: Then create a new file and name it 1-1
Jake:呃然后进去
Jake: Uh, then go in
Jake:进去新建一个202404
Jake: Go in and create a new one, 202404
其他人：0416昨天
Jake:从15开始的其实对151617
Jake: Start from 15, right, 15, 16, 17
Jake:你直接建吧
Jake: Just create it directly
Jake:然后
Jake: Then
Jake:到时候你看他创建日期是什么时候
Jake: Check the creation date when you look at it later
Jake:你就往里面拖
Jake:每一个视频
Jake: Each video
Jake:他有自己的创建日期
其他人：每个视频哦哦
其他人：这有什么快捷键能快速建文件夹的吗
Jake:快速干嘛啊
Jake: Why are you rushing?
Jake:啊对这这够快了
Jake: Oh right, this is fast enough
Jake:比迈克快多了
Jake: Much faster than Mike
Jake:哎迈克也很快
Jake: Hey, Mike is also fast
其他人：从2024
Jake:你写个python
其他人：对写个python
其他人：对python吧
Jake:你可以你可以建很多
Jake: You can, you can create many
Jake:你可以建到22
Jake: You can create up to 22
其他人：然后这个里面再写相机的那个
其他人：相机的编号是吗
其他人：比如说
Jake:对你编号在啊
Jake: Yes, put the number in
Jake:哎你这二是什么
Jake:没有没有没有你
Jake: No, no, no, you
Jake:你在我最外层
Jake: You are on my outermost layer
Jake:就这个你要你要
Jake: This one, you need, you need
Jake:拖到一个
Jake: To drag to a
其他人：建到20号可以吗
Jake:呃没关系
Jake: Uh, it's okay
Jake:你建到17也行
Jake:建到17吧
其他人：然后我把那些MP4拖到对应的里面吗
Jake:对你看到日期
Jake: Yes, you see the date
Jake:你看日期了吗
Jake: Did you see the date?
其他人：你为什么不把大文件夹复制粘贴呢
其他人：我这是从9开始是吗
其他人：哎刚刚那个盒呢哦在我这了
Jake:9号相机
Jake: Camera number 9
Jake:你的一号相机
Jake: Your camera number 1
Jake:你的壳还在吧
Jake: Your case is still there, right?
Jake:他从9号相机开始搞
Jake: He starts working from camera number 9
其他人：9到19
Shure: 搞定
Shure: Done
Jake:9到15 15
其他人：然后外面还要套个1楼吗
Jake:不用不用
Jake: No, no need.
其他人：9到15OK
其他人：这个好慢啊
Jake:对啊我我觉得不应该这么慢
Jake:气死我了靠
Jake: I'm so pissed off, damn it.
其他人：10十五分钟一个
Choiszt: 1234567就算6吧
Choiszt: 1234567, let's count it as 6.
其他人：两个小时
Jake:我原来想一个小时在这转一圈搞定
Jake: I originally thought we could finish a round in an hour.
Jake:他妈头崩了
Jake: Damn, my head's about to explode.
其他人：啥啥叫转一个小时搞定
Jake:是我原来还没有买这种卡
Jake: It's because I didn't buy this kind of card before.
Jake:所以说我得插到GoPro
Jake: So I have to plug it into the GoPro.
Jake:就是把那个充电线给插电脑上
Jake: Just plug the charging cable into the computer.
Jake:然后开始倒
Jake: And then start transferring.
Jake:然后每一个一个一个跑
Jake: Then run each one by one.
Jake:就是原来的方案是推着这个小桌子
Jake: The original plan was to push this small table.
Jake:然后推着到处跑
Jake: And push it around everywhere.
Jake:然后碰到傻逼了
Jake: Then we ran into an idiot.
Jake:哈哈哈太难了
Jake: Hahaha, it's too difficult.
Jake:太慢了又慢又麻烦
Jake: It's too slow, slow and troublesome.
Jake:对啊就两两个人
Jake: Yeah, just two people.
Jake:好歹一人一层啊
Jake: At least one person per floor.
Jake:我他妈一人15个
Jake: Damn it, 15 each for me.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 我一会在上面吃还是下面吃火锅
Shure: Should I eat hotpot upstairs or downstairs later?
Jake:火锅在下面吃
其他人：对其实现在没事了是吧
Jake:shoping
Jake:好好在下面吃
Jake: Okay, we'll eat downstairs.
Lucia: 那行
Lucia: Alright then.
Jake:呃我想一下在下面吃
Jake:可以在下面吃
Jake: We can eat downstairs.
Jake:你出来被拍吧
Jake: Come out and get filmed.
Jake:你要不就给点
Jake: If not, give me some.
Jake:你给点素材出来弹
Jake:给你你的座位嘛座位
Jake: Give you your seat, your seat.
Shure: 席地而坐
Shure: Sit on the ground.
Shure: 大象席地而坐
Shure: The elephant sits on the ground.
Jake:一个吉他
Jake: A guitar.
Jake:还是被扫过的
Jake: Still being swept.
Jake:这是一个赛博系统
Jake: This is a cyber system.
Shure: 是吗啊
Shure: Really?
Shure: 他有自己的生命了
Shure: It has its own life now.
Jake:对但是他不是赛博的
Jake: Yes, but it's not cyber.
Jake:你是赛博的
Jake: You are cyber.
Shure: 那也就是现在
Shure: So that means now...
Jake:呵呵哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha...
Shure: 就是凭空就有一个人
Shure: So, a person just appeared out of nowhere...
Shure: 有一把吉他在这里自己发声是吗
Shure: And there's a guitar here making sounds by itself, right?
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
其他人：就现在现在它导着就没事了呗
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 八个人再拿一个
Lucia: Eight people, grab one more.
Jake:9呢9
Jake:nine9 9号卡
Jake:刚刚是谁拿走的
Jake: Who just took it?
其他人：我没拿走刘帅
Jake:9号卡
其他人：9好在我那里
其他人：现在咋回事
Jake:闷逼了确实没事啊壳子
Jake: It's fine, no problem, show it.
其他人：壳在我这在我这里
Jake:亮出来有点底
Jake:少一个就傻逼一个
Jake: If one is missing, then one person is an idiot.
Jake:太他妈极限了
Jake: This is so damn extreme.
其他人：舒服了
Jake:舒服确实爽多了啊
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 对加入到歌单
Shure: Yes, add it to the playlist.
Shure: 然后放入到ego里面
Shure: Then put it in the dog.
Jake:以房间装扮吗
Jake: Is it for room decoration?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:房间装扮吗
Jake: Room decoration?
Shure: 我的房间好像没有什么太装扮的东西
Shure: My room doesn't seem to have much for decoration.
Jake:多少啊
Jake: How much?
其他人：加起来就30个
Jake:我不懂啊要不学学他一会
Jake: I don't get it, maybe learn from him for a while.
其他人：学学他直接拖
Jake:对
其他人：哎你这个为什么是
其他人：我也不知道啊
Jake:太难了
Jake: Too difficult.
其他人：啊这个还得删了是吧
Jake:对回
Jake: Yes, return.
Jake:回头删了已经
Jake:倒完才删
Jake: Delete after it's done.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：今天晚上怎么说
Jake:怎么这么说
Jake: Why would you say that?
其他人：需要在这吗还是回去
其他人：可以回去
Jake:确实可以回去
Jake: We can definitely go back.
其他人：就是go Pro晚上到几点
Choiszt: So, how late does the GoPro stay on at night?
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
其他人：如果有活我也能在这
其他人：没活我就跟他回去了
Jake:在一晚上了
Jake: All night long.
Jake:等一等让我睡个觉
Jake: Wait a moment, let me take a nap.
Jake:多一个人能让我多睡好几个小时
Jake: With one more person, I can sleep several more hours.
其他人：晚上给我戴个眼镜
Choiszt: Wear glasses for me at night.
其他人：我戴着眼镜去看一下欧冠
Jake:什么眼镜
Jake:这个眼镜
Jake:行牛逼
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Jake:那你留着吧
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：明天那个车开不了明天限行
Jake:什么狗啊
其他人：那个咖啡厅有个小边牧
Jake:哦
其他人：好像不能借过来
其他人：接过来太过分了
Jake:偷过来
其他人：但那个狗摸着好舒服
Katrina: 我昨天看见它了我昨天买咖啡的时候
Shure: 我们昨天看见他的衣服了
Shure: We saw his clothes yesterday.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:在哪呀
Shure: 那我们去扒他衣服去
Shure: Let's go take his clothes off.
Shure: 扒他裤子
Shure: Take off his pants.
Jake:对眼镜关了
Jake:没电了应该
Jake: Probably out of battery.
Jake:可能没电了
Jake: Might be out of battery.
Jake:storage应该还在
Jake:没电插充电宝吧
Shure: 那有一打刚才
Shure: There's a dozen just now.
其他人：这个中途断了也没事是吧
Jake:中断了再录录了再每人再看一下时间
Jake:救命哈哈
Jake: Help, haha.
其他人：下面那个时间是计时器的时间还是
Jake:计时计时
Jake: Timing, timing.
Jake:对对对然后每人都要看
Jake: Yes, yes, and everyone needs to watch.
Jake:每人都要看
Jake: Everyone needs to watch.
其他人：就比如现在看4点50
Jake:啊不不不
Jake: Ah, no, no, no.
Jake:一个秒表
Jake: A stopwatch.
Jake:一个精确到后几位的秒表
Jake: A stopwatch that measures down to the last digits.
其他人：那怎么知道就是今天下午
Jake:这个不重要
Jake: This is not important.
其他人：为什么
Jake:是不是今天下午命名
Jake: Are we naming it this afternoon?
Jake:上面规定具体时间不重要
Jake: The specific time set above is not important.
Jake:时间线比较重要
Jake: The timeline is more important.
Jake:就是不要那么具体
Jake: Just don't be too specific.
Jake:差个5分钟没关系
Jake: A 5-minute difference is fine.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
其他人：没连上吧
其他人：上一段开了的
Jake:先插电了
Jake: Plug it in first.
Jake:插电了有电吗
Jake: Is there power after plugging in?
Katrina: 快没有吗
Jake:没电它这像有电吗
Jake:不像有电
其他人：不是我充的时候等一下我再给你一个充电宝
Jake:哎呦呦没电了话
Jake: Oh no, there's no power.
Jake:哦对
Jake: Oh, right.
Katrina: 这啥意思
Jake:呃就是他出不了图
Jake: Uh, it can't display the image.
Shure: 这歌单成分太复杂了
Shure: 这没电了是吗
Jake:嗯
其他人：这充电宝咋回事
Katrina:  这这个也没导是吗
Jake:对这个没倒
Jake: Right, this hasn't been poured.
Jake:中午没倒
Jake: It wasn't poured at noon.
Katrina: 那还在吗
Jake:在在
Katrina: 那两个小时够吧
Jake:对妥妥的够
Jake:哎你命个名
Jake: Hey, you give it a name.
Jake:然后大家跟你对个齐
Jake: Then everyone will align with you.
Jake:对齐时间
Jake: Align the time.
Jake:然后又可以去玩
Jake: Then you can go play again.
Katrina: 我想去看一下小狗再回来
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes.
其他人：来张A4纸
Katrina: low battle
Jake:嗯充上就行
Jake: Hmm, just charge it, it's fine.
Jake:low 不low不重要
Katrina: 但是它不给开
Jake:因为太因为没电是吧
Jake: Because there's no power, right?
Katrina: 它正在chargeing但是它觉得太low了
Jake:现在多low啊
Jake: It's so low now.
Katrina: 百分之四
Jake:太low啊
Jake: So low.
Jake:10% 坐一会吧
Jake: 10%, let's sit for a while.
Jake:嘿你这个挺好
Jake: Hey, this is pretty good.
Jake:掌握了精髓
Jake: You got the essence.
Jake:在画画
Jake: Are you drawing?
Lucia: 不我在想
Lucia: No, I'm thinking.
Lucia: 我怎样能把那个他
Lucia: How can I make this room
Lucia: 这个房间设计的更好看一点
Lucia: look better.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:我去你这个是啥呀
Jake: Wow, what is this?
Alice:花
Alice: Flowers.
Jake:这什么材料呢
Jake: What material is this?
Alice:卫生纸
Alice: Toilet paper.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Wow.
Lucia: 哇好好看
Lucia: Wow, it looks so good.
Lucia: 你已经又上了一层颜色
Lucia: You've added another layer of color.
Jake:确实挺牛逼
Jake: That's pretty awesome.
Jake:不给我看是不
Jake: You're not letting me see it, huh?
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why not?
Lucia: 没有我正在想
Lucia: No, I'm just thinking.
Lucia: 我那个做成什么样的比例比较好
Lucia: I'm wondering what proportion would be best.
Lucia: 我打算拿一个渔网把它挂一下
Lucia: I'm planning to hang it with a fishing net.
Jake:我靠有你们好爽啊
Jake: Wow, it's so cool having you guys here.
Jake:你知道如果没有你们我现在是什么样
Jake: You know how I'd be without you all?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:自愿者六六台眼镜
Jake:哈哈哈 6台眼镜的人
Jake: Hahaha, six pairs of glasses people.
Jake:对啊他们可不敢
Jake: Yeah, they wouldn't dare.
其他人：然后这是九号.
其他人：啊还要给它打开然后再找
Jake:你开两个
Jake:你开两个页面
Alice:用点不常用的颜色
Alice: Use some of the less common colors.
Alice:要不然我心疼
Alice: Otherwise, I'd feel bad.
Jake:你打一局
其他人：卧槽真有
其他人：呃九
其他人：没有鼠标吗
Jake:啊鼠标有
Jake: Ah, there's a mouse.
Jake:只是我不用
Jake: I just don't use it.
Jake:我以为你们都不用
Jake: I thought you guys didn't use it either.
其他人：啊不用就不用
Jake:有的有的
Jake:你可以用
Jake:当然可以用
Jake: Of course, it can be used.
Jake:主要是位置不太大
Jake: The main issue is there's not much space.
Jake:这触摸板确实不太灵敏
Jake: This touchpad really isn't very sensitive.
其他人：主要苹果用惯了这是一坨
其他人：苹果能导吗苹果导不是快吗
Jake:嗯
Jake:嗯苹果应该能到
Jake: Yeah, Apple should be able to.
Jake:我不知道苹果
Jake: I don't know about Apple.
Jake:他不一定有苹果
Jake: He might not have Apple.
Jake:你的苹果没有那个
Jake: Your Apple doesn't have that.
Jake:那那个口
Jake: That port.
Jake:没有SD口
Jake: No SD port.
Jake:有SD啊
Jake:因为有SD
Jake: Because it has SD.
Jake:那就可以导
Jake:那你要有SD也要有USB
Jake: Then you need to have both SD and USB.
Jake:那能倒一个
Jake: Then it can be transferred.
其他人：但是没有硬盘你那还有硬盘吗
Jake:那那呃
Jake: So, um...
Lucia: 哇完美融入
Lucia: Wow, perfectly blended in.
Jake:其实也可以
Jake: Actually, it works.
Jake:共15台你三三三一人5台也行
Jake: We have 15 units, you can take 5 each, that's fine.
Jake:就是也不管一楼二楼也行
Jake: Doesn't matter if it's on the first or second floor.
Jake:这也是make sense
Jake: That also makes sense.
其他人：这个为什么进去以后就没有
其他人：他就没有日期了呢
其他人：为什么这个没有日期呢
Jake:呃你这个查看哎
Jake: Uh, you can check this.
其他人：行它这个就完事了
其他人：这个就删掉
其他人：然后15号15 16
Jake:行再来一台吧
Jake: Alright, let's get another one.
Jake:来三台联谈
Jake: Let's set up three units together.
其他人：嗯电脑吗
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, right.
Jake:呃不是还有一个
Jake: Uh, isn't there another one?
Jake:还有一个这个这个这个研究者就是
Jake: And there's another researcher, I mean...
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
其他人：这要插什么呢
Jake:再来一个硬盘呗
Jake: Let's get another hard drive.
Jake:555也不是一楼二楼啊
Jake:555能快一点吧
Jake: Wu, can it be faster?
Jake:也不一定
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake:说实话
Jake: To be honest.
Jake:不不不就就就三台硬盘
Jake: No, no, just three hard drives.
其他人：我觉得要不就这样吧
Jake:就这样吧就这样吧
Jake: That's it, that's it.
其他人：这样还能多歇一会
Jake:确实确实
Jake: Indeed, indeed.
Jake:多歇一会也行
Jake: We can take a longer break.
其他人：这样你导脑子是清醒的
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：导完这些都删了
Jake:保安都删了
Jake: The security deleted it all.
Jake:保安你看一眼视频差不多对不对
Jake: Security, take a look at the video, it's about right, isn't it?
Jake:一般我们看这个就是大小对不对
Jake: Usually, we look at the size, right?
Jake:对了就没问题
Jake: If it's right, there's no problem.
Jake:就是分屏
Jake: It's split screen.
Jake:一般我你看都全是分屏
Jake: Usually, you see, it's all split screens.
Jake:12个头对 12个屏
Jake: 12 heads, right, 12 screens.
其他人：其他的这个就都删了
Jake:删删删
Jake:好然后再装回去
Jake: Alright, then put it back.
Jake:装回到这个里边
Jake: Put it back into this.
Jake:一个屏幕四个屏
Jake: One screen with four screens.
其他人：其实这个直接点格式化也行
Jake:嗯行熟悉一下
Jake:没问题
Jake:你们有几个人一起一场
Jake: How many of you are in a group?
Jake:那个模拟答辩
Jake:今天早上10个
Jake: This morning there were 10.
Shure: 10个好像将近10个
Shure: 10, almost 10.
Jake:你第几个
Jake: Which number were you?
Shure: 我第
Shure: I was...
Shure: 不是谁谁自告奋勇
Shure: It wasn't like anyone volunteered.
Shure: 就是谁先来
Shure: It was just whoever came first.
Jake:你是好奋友
Jake: You were a volunteer.
Shure: 我第二个
Shure: I was the second one.
Shure: 我第一个
Shure: I was the first one.
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Impressive.
Shure: 没没没答上
Shure: No, no, I didn't answer.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 然后我后面的同学
Shure: Then the classmate after me...
Shure: 呃就是我女朋友
Shure: Uh, it was my girlfriend.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 她电脑突然放不出来了
Shure: Her computer suddenly wouldn't work.
Shure: 然后又借她电脑用一下
Shure: So she borrowed my computer for a bit.
Jake:哦你要帮帮那个忙
Jake: Oh, you had to help her out.
Shure: 然后所以就10点半正好答完
Shure: So, I finished answering right at 10:30.
Jake:所以最后他们10个人的话结束
Jake: So, in the end, did they finish with 10 people?
Jake:什么时候结束
Shure: 12点多
Shure: Around 12.
Jake:哦这么快
Shure: 9点到12点
Shure: From 9 to 12.
Jake:10 个人
Jake:谁是空卡
其他人：十号里面有但是没东西没录上
Jake:录上了就是有一些我用我手忙脚乱的导出来一些
Jake:在那个硬盘里边
Jake:我我把我把硬盘给你们
Jake:然后还是把硬盘给清出来
Jake:你你你你先整别的吧
Jake:USB卡比较重要
其他人：这就完事了
Jake:你你可以给他格式化了
其他人：11也没有
Jake:谢斌竹还在等着
其他人：11 也没有12 好
Jake:好
Jake:谢斌竹帮我把我的水给我水瓶
Jake:帮忙收点数据吧
Jake:多多多看看昨天买的东西
Shure: 好的
Jake:嗯
Jake:一些毫无逻辑的行为硬加一些QA
Jake:好吧你你你就出题
Jake:好吧你现在就哈
哈哈哈哈哈